Reia was founded in 2011
Seventh year of this year
And we just launched seven games.
That is the CYTUS series that players are familiar with.
"DEEMO", "VOEZ", etc.
All games are in more than 100 countries
And the region won the first place
That other type of game
Contains "Mandora" like casual
"Implosion" of the action RPG class
Almost all games we have in the store
I got the first place on the total list.
I think the game itself is created.
It is also like playing a game
It has a very artistic and subjective component at the perceptual level.
In rationality, you must also have a profound analysis of commerciality.
Then after the work is released
Can support yourself outside
Then make one can
a work that makes your creative desires satisfied
Development of a game
If there are good tools
It actually can greatly reduce the cost of communication
When Cytus II is on the shelves
Our Crash Rate is 8%
That's because there is a very convenient Android vitals dashboard background
Let us monitor which version is in
Or what are the problems on the models?
So after the instant adjustment
We then fell to 0.12%
Let it make a good
Stability score
That Google Play Console
Provides a great staged release feature
Like internal test
Can let our internal QA staff
You can play the latest version every day.
That Close test and Open test
Can let us limit all players worldwide
What kind of people do we want to play?
We are on the Play Console
You can see all the players in different languages ​​directly.
Give us feedback
And it will be translated directly into the language used by our developers.
That goes further
It goes to summarizing the different feedbacks
There may be a negative comment on the crash, it will be brought together
That is to say, there is a problem with the performance of the art.
Can greatly improve the efficiency of our development
The Google Play Console provides an A/B test feature
Through different store graphic design, or icon design
Then we can collect what kind of pixels everyone is
There will be a better conversion rate
The final result of our game page to
Download conversion rate increased by 10%
That is 4.8 percent higher than all games of the same type.
Then we think this will be a function that is very easy for developers.
In fact, we don’t just think of Raya as a game developer.
But think of it as a content provider
In fact, the platform will change with the times and technology.
But it really will keep the player in mind.
In fact, in the process of creation, and in the process of play.
The feelings obtained
So we will also want to say
Really create a touch that allows players to stay in the bottom of their hearts
And IP
This will be what Reya will do and will do in the future.